>> CONGRESSMAN GAETZ AND
CONGRESSMAN TURNER, THANK YOU.
NOW WE HAVE MORE EVIDENCE AND
CORRUPTION AT THE HIGHEST
LEVELS OF THE BUREAUCRACY.
JULY UNCOVERED DOCUMENTS SHOW
THE COPPED WITHOF
THE CONPED WITHOF
THE CONDUD WITHOF
THE CONDUITWITHOF
THE CONDUIT OTHOF
THE CONDUIT OFHOF
THE CONDUIT OF TF
THE CONDUIT OF THE DEEP STATE
BRUCE OHR WAS GIVEN A BONUS
AND A RAISE COMPLIMENTS OF
YOU, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
DURING THE VERY HEIGHT OF THE
RUSSIA WITCH HUNT.
BUT THAT IS NOT ALL.
YET ANOTHER DISCOVERY FROM THE
JUDICIAL WATCH IS REVALING HOW
THE CLINTON E-MAIL
INVESTIGATION WAS SO BOTCHED
THAT THE IMPORTANT
INVESTIGATORY NOTES ARE
TOTALLY MISSING AND OTHERS ARE
DAMAGED BEYOND REPAIR.
KNOWING TO SEE THERE, FOLKS --
NOTHING TO SEE THERE, FOLKS.
JOINING US WITH MORE IS
JUDICIAL WATCH PRESIDENT
FITTON AND THE FOX NEWS
ANALYST GREGG JARRETT.
THERE ARE INFORMATION
APPEARING ALL THE TIME THAT
KOLINICK IS RUSSIAN GUY BUT
THE GOVERNMENT USED HIM.
THIS WAS SO HORRIBLE FOR THE
DON TRUMP BUT HE WORKED WITH
THE COMPANY AND IT WAS PAID
FOR BY HILLARY.
BUT INFORMATION ON THE
CLINTONS IT ALL MAGICALLY
DISAPPEARS THROUGH THE BLACK
HOLE.
>> UNEQUAL JUSTICE AND
SELECTIVE PROSECUTION BECAME
HALLMARK OF THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION AND JAMES COMEY
AND RULE
AND AULE
AND ALAE
AND ALAN
AND RLAN
AND ROBN
AND ROBERT MUELLER.
ABEDIN SAID THERE WAS NO
HACKING OF THE CLINTON SERVER.
DOCUMENTS SHOW IT WAS SIMPLY
UNTRUE.
THE CHINESE HACKED HER SERVER
AND SHE KNEW IT.
SO THAT WAS A LIE.
THEY ALSO TOLD THE F.B.I. --
AGAIN THIS UNDER OATH -- WE
DON'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
HILLARY CLINTON USING A
PRIVATE UNAUTHORIZED SERVER.
THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT IT AND
COMMUNICATING ABOUT IT.
BUT THEY WEATHER NEVER
PROSECUTED.
COMEY WAS ASKED ABOUT IT.
WHY DIDN'T YOU PROSECUTE THAT?
OH, FAILING MEMORIES SHOULD BE
FORGIVEN.
SO IF YOU A FRIEND OF HILLARY
CLINTON YOU GET A FREE
PASSION.
IF YOU SO MUCH AS COUGH AND
SNEEZE IN THE VICINITY OF
TRUMP THE FULL FORCE OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WILL COME
AFTER YOU WITH A VENGEANCE.
>> AND MIKE FLYNN'S FAILING
MEMORY AND GEORGE
PAPADOPOULOS'S MEMORY WASN'T
FORGIVEN.
THEY WENT TO JAIL.
AND JUDICIAL WATCH HAS DONE
GREAT WORK AND THE RECENT
DISCOVERY OF THE MISSING
INFORMATION OF THE F.B.I.
I HAVE A THEORY.
TELL ME IF YOU THINK I'M
RIGHT.
THAT IS THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
OF THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY
NOTE WITH THE F.B.I., CORRECT,
SOME MISSING?
>> RIGHT.
>> IS IT POSSIBLE -- YOU KNOW
BETTER THAN I DO.
YOU F.O .I.D IT.
IS IT'S A DAMAGE ASSESSMENT
DONE BY THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY ABOUT THE HILLARY
CLINTON E-MAIL IF IT WAS
HACKED AND WHAT WAS OUT THERE?
>> WELL, THE DATES LINE UP.
THE MISSING MEETING NOTES ARE
FROM A MEETING THAT THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY HAD
WITH PETER STROZK AND COMPANY,
IT LOOKS LIKE.
ABOUT A MONTH AFTER THE
I.C.I.G. REFERRED IT TO D.O.J.
SO THEY HAD THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE REFER TO THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT HILLARY CLINTON FOR
THE INVESTIGATION OVER THE
MISSING E-MAILS AND THE
NATIONAL SECURITY
IMPLICATIONS.
THEY HAVE A MEETING ABOUT THE
ISSUE A MONTH LATER.
THE NOTES ARE NOWHERE TO BE
FOUND.
IT LOOKS LIKE IT LINES UP WITH
THE DISCUSSIONS THAT THE
AGENCIES HAD ABOUT WHETHER THE
CHINESE GAINED ACCESS TO HER
E-MAILS.
THE NOTES ARE GONE.
BECAUSE OF A LAWSUIT.
IT'S NOT VOLUNTARY
DISCLOSURES.
TO ME IT SHOWS THEY DIDN'T
CARE.
A SHAM INVESTIGATION.
THEY LOST THE NOTES.
WHO CARES?
LAST WEEK THEY ADMIT 302, FOUR
WITNESSES, INTERVIEW
STATEMENTS WERE MISSING.
IF YOU DON'T CARE ABOUT THE
INVESTIGATION AND YOU KNOW
IT'S WIRED YOU WON'T DO THE
BASICS LIKE KEEP NOTES OF THE
MEETINGS.
AND BE DILIGENT AND RECORD
EVERYTHING THAT HAPPENS.
>> SOMETHING I SAW IN THE
JUDICIAL WATCH REPORT IS THE
POTENTIAL THAT SOME OF THE
HILLARY CLINTON INFORMATION ON
THE SERVER MAY HAVE APPEARED
ON THE DARK WEB.
SOME OF IT WAS CLASSIFIED.
WITH THE CLASSIFIED MARKINGS
MARKED OUT.
>> SURE.
>> THIS IS STAGGERING
INFORMATION.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THE
SECRETARY OF STATE.
SHE IS NOT TRAFFICKING IN
LOW-LEVEL INFORMATION.
I WAS AN INTRODUCTORY SECRET
SERVICE WE WORKED THE TREASURY
CHECK CASES.
THEY WERE NICE TO WORK BUT NOT
NATIONAL SECURITY CASES.
THIS IS THE REAL DEAL.
SHE WAS THE SECRETARY OF
STATE.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
SHE JEOPARDIZED THE NATIONAL
SECURITY.
SHE DIDN'T CARE, OBAMA DIDN'T
CARE.
OBAMA WENT ON NATIONAL
TELEVISION, ON FOX NEWS WITH
CHRIS WALLACE AND SAID SHE
DIDN'T JEOPARDIZE NATIONAL
SECURITY.
SHE WAS A LITTLE CARELESS.
THAT WAS THE CLARION CALL TO
COMEY AND THE DEPARTMENT AND
JUSTICE TO STOMP THE FOOT ON
THE SCALES OF JUSTICE.
AND CLEAR HILLARY CLINTON EVEN
THOUGH THEY KNEW SHE COMMITTED
CRIMES.
MORE THAN 100 OF THEM
REPRESENTING 110 CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS ON HER UNAUTHORIZED
SERVER.
COMEY TWISTED THE LAW AND
CONVERTED THE FACTS TO ABSOLVE
HER MAKING THE ANNOUNCEMENT ON
THE DAY THAT HIS F.B.I.
FURTIVELY MEETING IN LONDON
WITH THE AUTHOR OF THE PHONY
DOSSIER.
THAT WAS THE BEGINNING OF THE
RUSSIA HOAX THAT BEGET THE
WITCH HUNT.
>> DOUBLING DOWN ON WHAT GREG
HAD TO SAY.
THE BEGINNING OF THE
INVESTIGATION HAS BECOME A
SCANDAL IN AND OF ITSELF.
THE F.B.I. STORY DOESN'T SEEM
TO MAKE ANY SENSE WHEN YOU
ANALYZE IT WITH THE CLEAR
EYES.
THEY SAID IT STARTED WITH A
GEORGE PAPADOPOULOS TIP TO
DOWNER AT THE END OF JULY.
JULY 31.
BUT THE PROBLEM IS WE HAVE
F.B.I. TWO WEEKS BEFORE,
MIDDLE OF JULY, BEFORE JULY 31
IN LONDON MEETING WITH THE
CHRISTOPHER STEELE AND THE
DOSSIER.
IS THE BIG SCANDAL THE FACT
THAT THE F.B.I. IS NOT TELLING
US THE FULL STORY THE ENTIRE
TIME ABOUT THE ORIGINS OF THE
CASE?
IS THAT WHAT BILL BARR IS
GOING TO GIVE US?
>> MUELLER DIDN'T TELL US THE
FULL STORY OF THE ORIGIN OF
THE CASE.
THEY SUGGESTED THAT IT STARTED
LATER THAN IT DID.
THE F.B.I. HASN'T TOLD US
ANYTHING.
IT'S ALL BEEN LEAKS AND
SUPPOSITION.
MUELLER WAS SUPPOSED TO TELL
US THE TRUTH.
AS YOU HAVE SEEN THE MUELLER
DOSSIER IS SHOWN TO BE A SHAM.
IF I WERE THE A.G. I WOULD
ISSUE A BLACK BOX WARNING WITH
THE MUELLER REPORT.
YOU CAN'T TRUST IT.
WE DISAVOW IT.
IT'S THERE IF YOU WANT TO LOOK
AT IT.
THERE MAY BE FACTS YOU CAN
DOUBLE CHECK BUT WE CAN'T
VOUCH FOR IT.
WE HAVE DOCUMENTS COMING OUT
FOR INSTANCE THAT BRUCE OHR IS
GETTING UNUSUAL BONUS, AT
LEAST GIVEN THE RECENT SALARY
HISTORY IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
RUSSIA GATE INVESTIGATION.
JUST ABOUT THE TIME HE IS
LAUNCHED BY THE F.B.I. AND THE
D.O.J. TO BE THE BACK CHANNEL
AS YOU POINTED OUT.
TO CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
AFTER THE F.B.I. FIRED HIM.
SO HE GETS A BIG BONUS.
THEN IT COMES OUT HE WAS
DEALING WITH CHRISTOPHER
STEELE ON THE DOWN-LOW BECAUSE
EVIDENTLY SESSIONS AND COMPANY
DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT IT SO THEY
REMOVED HIM.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
THEY KICKED HIM UPSTAIRS TO
THE INTERNATIONAL GROUP AND
GAVE HIM A RAISE.
>> GREGG, I HYPOTHESIZED FROM
THE START OHR IS THE KEY TO
THE WHOLE CASE.
HE IS INFORMATION LAUNDERER.
NOT MONEY LAUNDERING BUT
LAUNDERING INFORMATION.
MAKING ILL LEL JIT MATE
INFORMATION LOOK REAL BECAUSE
IT CAME IN THROUGH HIS
POSITION WITH HIS WIFE AND THE
D.O.J.
NOW IT LOOKS LEGITIMATE.
SIMPSON AND OHR THE STORIES
DON'T MAKE SENSE.
SIMPSON SAID HE CONTACTED THEM
AFTER THE ELECTION IN
THANKSGIVING.
AND CONTACTED OHR AROUND
BUT OHR IS SAYING HE MADE
CONTACT WITH SIMPSON IN
AUGUST.
SO OBVIOUSLY THE STORIES CAN'T
MARRY UP.
>> AND NELLIE OHR RECEIVED A
CRIMINAL REFERRAL BECAUSE OF
THAT VERY FACT.
BRUCE OHR AND ELTON
BRUCE OHR AND GLTON
BRUCE OHR AND GLEON
BRUCE OHR AND GLENN SIMPSON'S
TESTIMONY DON'T MATCH UP.
HE IS IN A WORLD OF TROUBLE SO
THAT IS WHY HE INVOKED THE
FIFTH AMENDMENT.
>> HE SAID I JUST MET OHR
AFTER THE ELECTION IN
NOVEMBER.
WHEN IN REALITY -- THAT
CHANGES THE WHOLE STORY AND IT
WILL GIVE SIMPSON A MOTIVE TO
SAY THAT.
>> THERE ARE SO MANY BAD
CHARACTERS IN THIS.
GLENN SIMPSON, CHRISTOPHER
STEELE, BRUCE OHR, NELLIE OHR.
THE OHRS, BY THE WAY, ARE
PROFITING BY THIS AT THE SAME
TIME THEY ARE PEDDLING THE
PHONY DOSSIER.
NOW WE LEARN TODAY THANKS TO
TOM FITTON AND JUDICIAL WATCH
OHR IS GETTING $28,000 BONUS
FOR THE WORK HE DID THAT
RESULTED IN HIS DEMOTION.
ONLY IN AMERICAN GOVERNMENT
CAN YOU PROFIT BY
MALFEASANCES.
>> WE PAID FOR IT.
YOUR TAX DOLLARS NOT HARD AT
WORK.
>> THE ATTORNEY GENERAL SHOULD
LOOK AT THE DOCUMENTS.
HIS AGENCY AND THE F.B.I. GIVE
TO JUDICIAL WATCH.
HE CAN DO THE PROSECUTIONS
THAT HE NEEDS TO BASED OVER
THAT.
INCREDIBLE.
IT IS ALL THERE IN THE PUBLIC
DOMAIN ALREADY.
>> I HOPE HE DOES.
THIS IS A SLAP IN THE FACE